I've been making vlogs for over five
years now and I've got a bunch of tips
and tricks that I would like to impart
to you now while I use Adobe Premiere
for my editing and I'm going to be
showing you stuff specifically in
Premiere in this video I understand that
everything I talk about all the
techniques are applicable to Final Cut
Pro Sony Vegas probably iMovie but
probably not Windows Movie Maker but you
know the point is these techniques of
generic across editors what this video
is not going to be is so we're going to
move our footage from the bin onto the
timeline because there are plenty of
videos online already that show you how
to edit anything you know literally the
building blocks of editing this video is
specifically about how to improve your
vlog through editing and in time-honored
tradition it takes to form the top 10
list
tip number one one of the defining
characteristics of the vlog as a format
is its liberal use of the jump cut and
the thing that people most frequently
get wrong when they're vlogging is
having awkward jump cuts because there's
too much silence between Clips you have
to have few frames of silence at most
you know if you're going to have
anything at all there will be occasions
when you might want to put a pause in
between Clips like you've come to the
end of the point where you want a
dramatic pause when doing that my tip is
put the sign up to the end of the first
clip not the beginning of the second
clip take a look at these two sequences
as if I was talking snowy I found the
window in the new house which
approximately pointed towards the
direction of our old house as if I was
talking snowy I found the window in the
new house which approximately pointed
towards the direction of our old house
they both had exactly the same amount of
silence in the transition but in the
first case the silence was at the end of
the first clip in the second case its
silence was at the start of the second
clip it blows much better at the end of
the first tip number two while we're on
the subject of transitions a really
useful thing that I just started doing
recently is the two frame transition now
the default transition for a lot of
editors is one second long which is a
really long fade but if you trim that
down to how they're only two friends
literally the shortest transition you
can have it becomes a really useful tool
because while the vlog is kind of
defined by the jump cut sometimes you
want just to soften it a little bit or
if you're going to bring in a bit of
b-roll over the top of your main blog
presage you might want to sort of have
it not be quite so you know bang and a
great way to do that is to have the two
frame transition in Adobe you can set
the length of the default here in
preferences and then there are shortcuts
to use it the default is controlled D
for just video and ctrl shift D for just
audio and to be honest sometimes I just
take a whole vlog and across every
transition just do the audio to frame
transition because it makes things flow
just a little bit better but you know
that doesn't always apply check number
three straying into the territory of
editing 101 here but it is something
that needs to be said for certain
people's blogs make sure you are
exporting your vlog at the same frame
rate that you shot him so in the UK
you're probably shooting at 25 frames
per second don't just use a generic
project that has 30 frames per second
because if you do there will be split
frames or it's kind of fading in between
the two and it just looks a little bit
jarring it's a super simple thing to do
and it's only that actually took me
quite a long time to learn but match
your input fps to your output it's
probably 25 and UK it's probably 30 if
you're in the States
now living on to a bunch of tips about
using music in your vlogs number 4 where
to find music there are plenty of places
online to get either free to use music
or very cheap to license music the
classic one that is used on YouTube is
incompetent run by Kevin MacLeod include
links to all these by the way in the
description but also within YouTube
there is an order
library of stuff that is free to you to
use to find it go on the creator studio
go to create and then first thing that
should come up is the audio library go
nuts that stuff's free if you want
something that's a little bit different
or new it's possible to search
SoundCloud by tags for free to use or
free to use of modification do be
careful because sometimes remixes crop
up on this that will be content flags
because the person who made the remix
didn't get the rights to use the music
in the first place and then if you're
willing to pay a little bit of money and
I'm talking like seven quid so that's
what like ten dollars you can buy a
whole bunch of music in EP form from
David cutter who has his own website
again link down there
which is great and that specifically
tailored to vlog so that's the kind of
stuff that people like KC nice tat use
tip number five and if you're going to
take anything away from this video for
the sake of like improving your
production this is the one to remember
learn how to use equalizers to make
yourself heard over music a really
common thing that you might want to do
is to have yourself talking so you're
out about Anna might wanna put music
underneath to make it more interesting
maybe you want it to be part of a
montage but if you're not careful you
might sound something like this but when
I doing research-wise opening mode or in
writing mode but with a little magic you
can make it sound like this feel like
what I'm doing research I'm either very
much in cooling mode or in writing mode
much more understandable right to do
this get an equaliser in your editing
software in Premiere that's a simple
parametric EQ you want to take your
music and you want to reduce the volume
of frequencies around a thousand Hertz
and you want to do that because that's
roughly the part of the spectrum where
the human voice sets in Premiere it
looks like this you're taking your
simply key you keep the key value as it
is and just reduce by my six to eight
decibels maybe in Final Cut Pro I think
you just want to put your vocal boost on
your music clip but then set the amount
to be negative like negative thirty
percent and this has the effect that you
heard earlier it reduces those
frequencies in the music so it means
your voice can stand out over the top of
it that much easier click number six and
the last of the audio tips learn how to
do a little bit of audio mastering
mastering is just the process of
rounding out the edges of your audio and
making sure that it's well audible and
sounds good from ya the simplest way to
do this is to go on your audio track
mixer click the little arrow on the left
that pulls up these places to put effect
go on your master and then put in a
multiband compressor
I will get two other editors in just a
second use the broadcast preset and then
fiddle with the threshold at which the
compressor starts to work and basically
if you do this right you've got a really
quite well mastered audio track feel
flogged and for a vlog it doesn't have
to be perfect that's what I do for mine
now to use an editor that doesn't have
an audio channel master I think Vegas
does bi can't remember what you can do
is just exploit your vlog and then rip
the audio from it and edit that
separately in a program like audacity
which is free basically what you want to
do is apply a little bit of compression
and there's no one magic arts for this
like there is in Premiere there's no
broadcast preset in audacity I don't
think basically you just want to get it
so the audio doesn't vary too much in
volume and then you can use a feature
like normalize to make sure that it's a
appropriate volume very hand wavy here
but it's kind of a detailed subject tip
number seven don't just think
chronologically certainly the easiest
way to edit the vlog is just dump all
the footage from your camera or your
phone into your timeline and then just
trim it and release it cutting out the
gaps that's fine that's one way to do a
block but it's so much more you can do
than that you don't have to obey like
the flow of time as you perceived it one
of the defining characteristics of a
vlog is that it is like a personal
experience it's how you experience what
you filmed but you can play with that
you can experience stuff not necessarily
in the order that you show it to the
audience the king of doing this as so
many things in vlogging is of course
Casey nice step slows down time speeds
up time jumps around and he's basically
treating it like storytelling and that
makes it a little bit different from a
true vlog but it shows the potential of
what you can do with the format so use
stuff like time lapses when you're
editing just shoot a really long clip
what I do with this camera is just shoot
for half an hour and then compress that
down into like 10 seconds if I'm
shooting clouds going across the sky it
shows the fact that time has moved on or
if you're moving from place to place put
the camera on the dashboard if you're
driving and let it run for half an hour
and speed it up it shows even move
places equally another really easy thing
to do if you have a camera that can
shoot at 50 frames per second if you
live in UK 60 frames per second in the
u.s. is to shoot it twice the frame rate
and then edit it at 25 frames a second
if you in UK or 30 frames a second
u.s. which gives you a slow-mo effect
and it's super easy to do on cameras I'm
using a canon g7x you can do it on this
this technique is particularly useful if
you want to do a voiceover over the top
of your footage in you want to make it
look a little bit arty or if you want
slowdown sports footage to make it look
really epic or if you just want to make
something look a little bit more
poignant but the takeaway is don't just
treat time as being a constant speed
from the beginning to the end you can do
so much more than that tip number eight
use zoom as a tool now you probably
either found that really obnoxious or
maybe a little bit cool as with so many
things editing this is a matter of
personal preference but you have the
ability to zoom in on parts of the frame
and this can be for comedic effect it
can be to add emphasis it can be to
point out details the point is you only
have one camera when you're vlogging
probably but that doesn't limit you to
only one focal length or one set up you
can trim the information you have to
convey a different story so you can do
what I did earlier and use zoom as a
transition or to make it appear that you
have multiple cameras or a technique I
really like doing in Premiere often in
conjunction with a time-lapse is the
slow zoom out so set a small zoom I mean
like at the start and you might have
your scale as a hundred percent by the
end of a four second clip you might have
a hundred and three percent the effect
that this has is what's known as a Ken
Burns if it's a still I don't know what
it's called if it's a video um but
basically it adds a little bit more
flavor to a shot and given that you're
so limited in the kit that you have when
you're vlogging you kind of got to
squeeze everything out of the footage
you have and scale or zoom is a super
easy way to do that tip number nine
we're nearly there think about that
actually no don't but while I didn't in
this video I decided that I didn't like
what I originally set for tip number
nine so I'm going to change it out
that's actually a free editing tip if in
doubt leave it out instead of the meta
point that I was going to talk about I'm
going to steal a point from Tony Jerry's
amazing YouTube channel every frame a
painting which is by far the best ET
channel I've yet seen about editing and
that tip is that if you're trying to
connect to clips and make the Edit as
seamless as possible
tip number nine cut on movements this
can take the form of a transition like a
whip pan or if you move a camera between
two different setups and you want to
make it look like you didn't and it was
a spontaneous thing a very Casey and I
start starting to do then cut
when the subject which is what are going
to you is moving this is a very
cinematic technique if you'd like to see
how a film director uses this then an
example would be like that this is all
taken from Tony's video about the
legendary director Akira Kurosawa if
you'd like to learn more about this I
highly recommend to check out that video
which I will link below anyway back to
past Simon and lastly tip number 10 edit
the best way to get better editing is to
edit I was told once start of my
youtubing career that home the first 50
videos you make are terrible once you
accept that and you make them you move
on and it is so so true and it sucks to
be told that someone is just starting
but when you start you're probably
terrible and arguably nowhere is that
more true than in editing when you're
starting out you don't really know what
you're doing and that's absolutely fine
if you're watching this and you haven't
edited a vlog before I implore you the
best way to get better editing vlogs is
to edit vlogs I've made probably
hundreds by now and in them I see huge
amount of improvement over time like if
I look at my it might first look they
are terrible but I won't be able to make
the vlogs that I make now which I think
kind of good without making the mistakes
early on now in this video I've tried to
help you to not make the same mistakes
that I made in try and sort of speed up
your process but you only get good at
editing you've just got to do it it's
like muscle memory basically you don't
get good at the guitar by reading books
about how to play the guitar or watching
tutorials by how to play the guitar you
needed a little bit of that but you get
good by doing it I put a recap of all
the points up here if you did like this
video then do like hit on them on
YouTube and share it with people that
you think might be interested in it you
can also subscribe to me if you want to
get more content like this if this does
well I will do more practical kind of
videos as I said mostly what I do is
vlogging but I'd be interested to do
more technical videos like this if you
have any editing tips of your own be
they as specific or as generic as you
like put them down there in the comments
thank you again for watching and I hope
to see you around on this channel in the
future
[Music]